[Music]
it was crazy we did a show in
Minneapolis and we walked outside I'm
sort of snowing and it was a big shadowy
figure in the alley who wants to sue you
who the carrot wants to serve you I said
who's a kid purrs I said okay so we go
to Paisley Park um it was crazy and they
had us weigh in you know and it was like
they had me in this white room I said I
feel a weird man by myself waiting do
you get annoyed waiting I mean hell no
wait it's not 4:00 in the morning and I
had all my comedian friends with us and
be like and that [ __ ] came out
dog he had a one-piece on like you know
like Dorothy hell star see how my body
fathers with his twisted with with the
boots on in it so they wherever he was
they were showing him in this and there
was like Chris really they like hold on
he'll be ready just say select me and he
had his head mm the most beautiful man
I've ever seen in my life and me and
Mohamed like [ __ ] this [ __ ] is pretty
yeah he's pretty a handsome man I'm a
pretty look better than Halle Berry
I remember asking for a picture oh I
[ __ ] up yeah because he's Jehovah
Witness he didn't want you doing that
all of whatever I did I did not [ __ ]
that well you know yeah he did that's
embarrassing I did that to Paul
McCartney cuz my daughter was with me
and I said hey uh Paul's can take it he
did one of those moves Felix yeah yeah
we'll get right back to that and and
Chris Rock was watching me he's laughing
because you [ __ ] oh I [ __ ] up and it
was the camera it was a disposable it
was this one hold on I ain't got none in
this league I got more than this hey
suddenly get that 50 says I don't do
this